can we just talk about your suit like
like this should just be all about your
suit this is it is brilliant it is so
good and it's I sleep in this yes looks
like you're a comedian impersonator
you're Canadian and you were just on a
GT yeah now that it's kind of over Kenny
did you come at but Chester could
reflect the experience you had well very
my wife that was quite a bit of time to
roots like that yeah I found that I went
through a stage of withdrawal mm-hmm cuz
being on the show you get all that
attention and your gogogo friend follow
the yellow brick road follow the yellow
brick road follow the yellow brick road
I first went under like I was very
nervous I thought you know what Greg
just throw yourself on stage you've got
nowhere else to go yeah and so I did and
I yeah and then when I finished it I
felt like you know when you watch the
Olympics and a skater skates their
perfect routine that's what I felt like
I am this release this flood of emotion
and I just it felt so great
[Applause]
now you've worked with before with Dave
Chappelle Chris Rock you've had lined
with them
you've been opened for Celine Dion oh
yeah that was wonderful
dude she is so incredibly nice yeah just
like oh I'm so happy
please don't take my limo you can go
anywhere you think oh really wow this is
fantastic
now you're gonna be on tour as well in
Ontario that's what can people expect on
your show it's kind of a one-man variety
show really yeah can you give us a
little taste of some of the
impersonations you're gonna be doing on
the show okay okay the dark side young
Skywalker she need your father and the
dark side of the force
[Laughter]
[Music]